-Finally, guys, it is Tuesday.
It is time for "WePost."
Here we go.
-♪ WePost ♪
♪ WePost ♪
-Now, welcome to "WePost."
This is where we
as a group decide something
that we should post
on the socials.
I'm going to show you
five different posts
and we're all going
to vote on whether
you like each one or not.
You all have voting clickers
at your seats.
Everyone should have one.
The green, thumbs up, of course,
is if you enjoy it,
hopefully you will press
that a lot.
The red, thumbs down.
If you don't enjoy it,
you can vote for all of them.
It doesn't matter.
You can vote for none of them.
If you don't feel like playing,
just sit back and watch.
I just want you
to have a good time.
Higgins, Roots,
you have your clickers?
-Got it.
-Alright, very good.
Whatever postest gets the
mostest gets posted.
-Wow.
-You should have seen
your face right there, Tariq.
You got roasted
by the hostess.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
[ Laughter ]
Here we go. Here we go.
The first post.
-[ Laughs ]
-Yeah!
-Zinger!
[ Trills tongue ]
-The first post is...
Yeah, they don't leave.
They go, yeah.
Are you going to
contribute to this or...?
Yeah, they just --
they just want to read the text.
Alright,
the votes are in.
I don't feel great
about this one.
Let's see the results.
Well, not bad. I like it.
125, very positive.
I like this crowd.
They're very positive.
They didn't have to --
they didn't have to do that.
-No, they did not.
-No.
They did not have to do that.
They were very nice.
I owe you guys one.
Alright, there you go.
This next one says...
Go on in. Go.
If they invite you in,
go on in.
Go sit on the couch.
Yeah, make friends.
Alright, let's see the results
of this one.
Yeah.
Oh, wow!
That was almost 100.
-Yeah, 21.
-That was almost 100 percent
of the audience.
Alright. Wow.
At this point, I could probably
tell who didn't vote for it.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-This next one says...
Come on, figure it out.
What does it mean?
I'm not defrosting butter.
I don't know what that is.
Alright, here we go.
Let's see the results
on this one.
Whoa, not bad, though.
These are good.
Alright. About right.
About right.
[ Applause ]
I think this next one
is going to be the one.
You think is the winner.
Is it going to be 181?
-What's in the lead now?
-Candy, 181.
-Candy.
-Candy. What was the candy one?
Your kid, you tell your kids,
don't talk to strangers.
Then one day you go,
"forget about it."
-Yeah, Halloween.
-Yeah.
-Should probably call that one
the Halloween one
instead of the candy one.
-Oh, because there's
also a candy one.
-I probably wouldn't call it...
-What?
-Well, sometimes people
don't give out candy.
-Give out like what?
-Like, let's say raisins.
-Raisins.
[ Laughter ]
You have a giant thing
of raisins at your house
for every kid that comes up.
-We had one house
that used to give out
bags of pennies.
-Really?
-Yeah.
-Ziploc bags.
Not even Ziploc bags.
You know those bags
that you would fold over?
-Yeah.
-Tuck -- tuck them in.
-Sandwich bags.
-Tuck the bag.
into the other bag.
-That's not good.
-Yeah, pennies. I go, "Yeah."
-Hey, sounds good.
I'll throw these at your car.
[ Laughter ]
You're saying this
one's the winner?
-I think this one people are
going to maybe standing ovation.
-Really?
-Whoa.
-No, no, I'm just joking.
-Wow.
-I don't think standing,
but it could be kind of funny.
You never know.
Hey, you guys want
to make history?
[ Cheering ]
No one would care about that.
-[ Laughs ]
Alright, this last one is...
♪♪
Seeds on the outside.
IDGAF.
-[ Laughs ]
-Wow.
-You put a lot of pressure
on that one.
[ Laughs ]
Let's see what it is.
-Let's see the results.
[ Laughter ]
[ Sad tone plays ]
Standing ovation?
Standing O.
Look at this.
Standing ovation.
They didn't like it.
They didn't like it one bit.
They didn't like.
Guys, we have a winner.
It is Halloween right there.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm going to post this
during the commercial break.
If you see it on your feed,
give it a like, okay?